does feel as if the momentum is behind
Boris Johnson to be the next prime
minister and he of course has said that
he is prepared to take the UK out of the
EU without a deal if that's what it
takes
are you gonna try and stop him yes
because it would be completely
irresponsible for any Prime Minister to
do that because of the economic damage
it would do to the country we took ever
Goodin Segen in the select committee
this week from representatives of
manufacturers car makers farmers the
food and drink industry and you just
have to look at what they said they said
it would be disastrous it was simply not
an option
economic vandalism were the words used
by the representative of make UK that
represents manufacturers in the United
Kingdom how can any Prime Minister
advocate that and what is clear Sophie
as we know already is that the House of
Commons does not support a no deal
breaks it and there is no mandate from
the referendum for a no deal breaks it
because the leave campaign never argued
for you say there's no mandate but at
the same time some people who voted
leave in that referendum will be looking
at MPs like yourself and thinking look
who's just trying to stop the Democratic
will okay perhaps people would many
people would have liked to leave with a
deal but if it was a choice between not
leaving at all and leaving without a
deal that is what they were going for
they believe that that is a true
bracelet well and he's better to leave
as well well I don't think it is because
look what is occupied British politics
for the last three years why is
Parliament deadlocked because the
referendum didn't decide what the future
economic relationship with the EU would
be after we have left and the current
prime minister Theresa May tried three
times to get Parliament to approve her
deal we did not and whoever wins the
Tory leadership contest will return to
find the same numbers in the House of
Commons and the last time we voted
formally in specifically on whether we
supported and no do brexit or not that
was defeated by 400 votes - lofty you
lost your last week they didn't you it's
not as if it's always clear-cut that
you're always winning all the votes that
you put forward well the vote last week
was on was a procedural motion a
business motion to as we say booked a
slot on the parliamentary agenda but the
last time we voted just on the question
does Parliament approve or not approve a
No Deal breaks it it
a huge defeat for an O do brexit and
there is no mandate for it and I don't
think whoever wins can somehow claim
that being elected by the Conservative
Party membership is a mandate for
something that Parliament has already
rejected and was not argued for by the
leave campaign during the referendum I
just wonder will you be able to do what
you hope you have got much time have you
I mean Parliament breaks over some are
you taking all of August off come back
for a couple of weeks then your party
conference season we're supposed to be
leaving on October have you got time to
do this well it is going to be difficult
but the same problem will apply to the
new prime minister because the idea that
the withdrawal agreement is going to be
reopened in negotiations that used made
it very clear it won't but not I think
there are one or two other options using
the parliamentary rule book to enable
MPs to do their job which is to express
their view but look if it comes down to
it and the House of Commons votes to
pass a motion to say this house does not
agree to the United Kingdom leaving the
EU without an agreement is it seriously
being argued by whoever becomes Prime
Minister that they're going to say to
MPs I'm going to ignore what you have
just said I don't think that that is a
politically or indeed a constitutionally
sustainable position and that's why I've
come to the conclusion and a growing
number of MPs have although we are not
yet a majority there the only way to
break the deadlock is to present the
real choices to the British people on
the one hand this is what leave looks
like and on the other hand this is the
option of remain I don't know whether
the British people have changed their
minds or not because the other thing
we've learned Sophie after three years
is that the promise that was offered we
can have all our sovereignty back said
the leave campaign but don't worry we're
going to maintain all of the economic
benefits David Davis you see the exact
same benefits doesn't this just feed
into people's suspicions then you say
look we're just trying to avoid the
economic vandalism of a No Deal
and yet people will hear you talking
about another errand and think this is
what it's about I knew it all along it's
about MPs trying to block bright said no
it's about taking the real choice three
years on back to the bridge people and
that is democratic after all as you know
Sophie the Prime Minister tried twice
to return to the House of Commons to get
us to vote for her deal and said it was
democratic I don't disagree with that I
think the government was entitled to do
it you might call it in advised but if
it's Democratic to ask MP's whether
they've changed their mind about the
Prime Minister's deal is it actually
undemocratic to say the British people
we're stuck now you make criticizes for
the fact that Parliament is deadlocked
but we can't go on like this because
whether you are a brick sit here or a
remainer
the damage that is being done to our
international reputation to our economy
from the uncertainty that we haven't yet
resolved this question it seems to me
that's the only way you can sort this
out a quick thoughts from you on the
idea of probing Palme it's something one
of my guests on the show has talked
about Dominic Raab if he becomes Prime
Minister he hasn't ruled out the idea of
effectively suspending Parliament if it
tries to block No Deal it would be
scandalous to use that to try and it in
effect shut the doors of the House of
Commons so that MPs can't meet an
expressive view we are elected as
members of parliament to represent our
constituents and we can't do our job if
our locked out and I simply don't think
it's going to happen
okay now I'm keen to talk to you about
another story that's been in the news
today attacks on to all tankers listen
to in the Gulf of Amman now the Foreign
Office and the US have pointed the
finger at Iran Jeremy Corbyn has tweeted
and this is what he said about what
happened he said without credible
evidence about the tanker attacks the
government's rhetoric will only increase
the threat of war what do you make of
jeremy corbyn's response we need to see
the evidence and therefore we need an
international investigation some of the
tankers have been towed into port they
need to be examined and I think the
results of that should be reported to
the United Nations because it's really
important that we see the evidence so
you don't believe the Foreign Office I
don't know the honest answer is I don't
know and Laurie you and nor does anybody
else now as the evidence is gathered
then people can make their judgement and
I think the United Nations is the right
place to do that the second thing I
would do is if these attacks continue
then the international community ought
to takes
to protect vessels that are passing
through the Straits of Hormuz that has
happened in the past during for example
the iran-iraq war but thirdly we have to
address the cause of the tension with
Iran which was the United States
decision to withdraw from Iran nuclear
deal now it wasn't perfect and there are
other things that Iran is doing that are
very destabilizing in the region their
holding of Nazanin zagara Ratcliffe who
started her hunger strike yesterday he's
outrageous and the Iranian government
should release her back to her family
and her daughter and her husband as soon
as possible but the Iran nuclear deal
was the result of patient difficult
diplomacy and almost everyone except the
United States accepted that Iran was
abiding by the terms of the deal now
it's facing the sanctions if it is
undertaking these attacks well it's it's
of course completely wrong of them to do
so but we have to address the root
causes and we cannot have a conflict and
therefore we need to de-escalate the
tension rather than to Ratchet it up